Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous etactivez la petite cloche !
Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Aujourd'hui c'est mercredi etcomme d'habitude
je réponds aux questions que vous m'avez posées
en commentaires des vidéos
qui ont étépubliées ces dernières semaines.
C'est parti !
Une question qui concerne une vidéo
qui a été publiée
il ya quelques semaines,
au début de l'automne même !
Question de abdou 23 :
" D'où vient le mot moutarde ? ".
Eh bien ce mot est composé du latin
" mustum " et " ardens ".
" mustum " désigne le moût c'est-à-dire
le verjus, le jus de raisin non fermenté qui entrait
à l'origine dans la fabrication de lamoutarde.
Et " ardens " qui donne le verbe " arder "
qui signifie " brûler ".
Une racine que l'on retrouve
d'ailleurs dans le mot " ardent ".
" Moutarde " signifie donc un moût brûlant.
Une question de Swann GUIBERT
sur les feuilles d'automne :
" C'est quoi la chanson que tu fredonnes
au début de la vidéo ? "
je ne laconnais pas.
C'est tout à fait possible hein.
C'est une très vieille chanson qui s'intitule
" Colchiquesdans les prés ".
Alors personnellement,
je l'ai apprise à l'école lorsque j'étais en CP.
C'est unechanson qui a traversé le temps.
Elle a été reprise par de nombreux artistes :
Francis Cabrel notamment
et même par le rappeur Madlib !
Pour info,
les colchiques sont des plantes vivaces
de la familledes liliacées
comme l'ail
et comme le dit la chanson :
" Eh bien quand les colchiques fleurissentdans les prés,
c'est la fin de l'été ".
Une question de Théo Steinlen concernant
la vidéo sur le VendéeGlobe :
" Dis Jamy, pourquoi parle-t-on de pot au noir ?
Quelle est l'origine ? "
Eh bien les marins parlent dupot au noir
pour désigner une zone qui est très instable
et qui se trouve au niveau de l'équateur.
On peut y rencontrer des pluies diluviennes,
des vents qui soufflent dans toutes les directions
maisaussi
une mer d'huile sans un souffle de vent pendant des jours.
Alors on ne sait pas trop d'oùça vient
pas forcément du monde marin d'ailleurs.
On sait qu'à la fin XVIIe siècle
lorsqu'on jouaità colin-maillard,
eh bien on lançait un " gare pot au noir "
à celui qui avait les yeux bandés,
etqui risquait de se cogner ou de se blesser.
Et on lui éviter ainsi
de se faire un " noir ".
Aujourd'huion dirait plutôt un " bleu ".
Une autre hypothèse avance, qu'à l'époque de l'esclavage,
les naviresnégriers
qui restaient englués
pendant plusieurs jours dans cette zone,
passaient par dessus bord leshommes malades
pour éviter les contaminations.
Quoi qu'il en soit les skippeurs du Vendée Globe
redoutent cette zone
dans laquelle ils peuvent rester bloqués
pendant plusieurs jours.
Une zonequ'ils traversent deux fois :
une fois à l'aller
et une fois au retour.
A propos du Vendée Globe,
unepetite précision.
Je me suis un petit peu emballé sur l'itinéraire des bateaux.
Non, ils ne naviguent pas
dans l'océan Austral
ils tournent autour en passant par l'océan Indien
et le Pacifique Sud.
Un grandmerci aux Épicurieux
qui me l'ont fait remarquer.